good morning hickets tuesday i've been
thinking a lot about vaccines and
inoculation i mean for the obvious
reason but also because our community's
book club life's library has been
reading you abyss's brilliant book
on immunity i should say that lex
library is an online book club where a
lovely group of people read books
together and discuss them our annual
membership enrollment period begins
this friday and you should totally
become a member and or gift a
subscription to a friend links in the
doobly-doo but right this book on
immunity which was selected by our guest
curator celesting
really deepened my understanding of
immunity and inoculation and the book
achieved something really remarkable
because it's like a page-turning history
about vaccines and disease and our fears
about them
but it is not centered on individuals
like most non-fiction i read and almost
all fiction i read is centered on
individuals and they're highly
individualistic individual choices
bending the arc of some larger story
and i'm not like opposed to those books
i mean for one thing i've written some
but also i do think the choices of
individuals bend the arc of the human
story
when we think of human history though as
primarily the exploits of powerful or
lauded or brilliant individuals
there's just so much we miss like here's
how i always heard the story of the
smallpox vaccine in the late 18th
century a brilliant young scientist
named edward jenner noticed that
milkmaids were routinely infected with a
relatively mild disease called cow pox
which seemed to make them immune to the
much more serious disease of smallpox
having made this discovery jenner
borrowed the eight-year-old son of his
gardener made two small
cuts in the boy's arm and then put some
pus from a cowpox pustule
into the wound the boy got a fever but
recovered and was thereafter immune from
smallpox
word of this wonder spread and suddenly
one of the world's deadliest diseases
was completely preventable
like a lot of great stories this one
isn't exactly untrue it just isn't the
whole truth for one thing jenner did not
discover that milkmaids were immune to
smallpox
lots of people knew this including
milkmaids for whom not dying of smallpox
was one of the chief perks of the gig
also there were already many strategies
for smallpox inoculation like in china
for instance for centuries people had
been inhaling dried smallpox scabs in
order to induce a mild version of the
disease and thereafter immunity there
were also many effective strategies for
inoculation in african communities like
you know cotton mather of salem witch
trials fame he's often credited in
america for having
invented smallpox inoculation but he
learned the technique from an enslaved
african named onesimus like when mather
asked
nesimus have you ever had smallpox
anessimus was like
yes and no mather later wrote that
onesimus quote told me that he had
undergone an operation that had given
him
something of the smallpox and would
forever preserve him from it
he described the operation to me and
showed me in his arm the scar
now there are important differences
between the variation techniques
promoted by people like mather and true
vaccination but several other people
independent from jenner were doing very
similar work on smallpox vaccination at
the time because true innovation is
almost never about
a heroic individual succeeding via the
sweat of his randian brow
and almost always about a growing body
of expertise and
evidence making new breakthroughs
possible lastly and most importantly
jenner's work did not like
end smallpox by the end of the 19th
century smallpox vaccination was
extremely safe and effective so we knew
how to prevent the disease
and yet in the 20th century smallpox
killed over 300
million people many of them children and
most of them living in places
impoverished by colonialism none of this
is to say that edward jenner's work was
unimportant it was extremely important
it contributed to our eventual
eradication of smallpox but he was
participating in a massive
centuries-long
species-wide collaboration if a new
vaccine is coming and
god i hope it is let's not build a
statue of one person
or another let us instead build
monuments to the sprawling cooperation
of thousands of people who shared their
work
openly and efficiently so that together
we might achieve what we cannot achieve
alone
shared immunity hank i'll see you on
friday